good morning or good evening everyone my
name is
i'm a phd student at columbia university
i hope you are all doing well
i'm going to talk about natural language
processing
for arabic language so here are the
agenda
i'm going to start first with the
national languages
and then talk about arabic language and
specifically
then give overview of natural language
processing its applications and tools
and then
uh nlp some data sets and tools
so what are natural languages there are
any language that has evolved naturally
in humans
examples include arabic english french
unlike constructed languages like
programming languages
python java c
they aren't designed so there's no
previous grammar
rules for natural languages and they are
inherently
ambiguous which means that you might
have
one word that has two meanings like
the word uh bank can be
riverbank or uh financial bank
um also uh towards mentioning that all
human language devices in the world
are natural however
there has there are some efforts to
standardize languages
some languages have more standardization
than others
for instance modern standard arabic or
has a different language academy
french language also has a french
academy
while english does not have academy that
regulates
english language prescription
prescriptions include dictionaries so
linguist design dictionaries list of
words their meaning
there are some languages that uh
regulate
uh orthography or spelling like the
german language uh also prescriptions
include grammar and in real world
people do not follow these
standardization
so people not necessarily speak
exactly as the prescriptions given by
the language activities
arabic is one of the uh
un official languages and it's uh the
sixth
most spoken language in the world with
more than
360 million speakers
and it exhibits an interesting
uh linguistic phenomenon
called diglosia
where two or more varieties of the same
language
are used so in arabic people
speak both modern standard arabic or
fosha
and different dialects and
these dialects are different than msa in
different ways
they have different lexicon
they have different morphology which
means that
words have different structure between
different dialects and the
msa and they have different grammar as
well
msa of course has mainly written
it's well-regulated there has been a lot
of effort in
standardizing and regulating
msa however it's no one's native
language so people
do not learn fosa in natural ways they
learn it at school and it's used in
formal situations on the other hand uh
dialects are mainly spoken
they are used in daily basis
and dialects are native language for
arabic speaker and they are dominant in
social media
also too uh in linguistics we
say that two languages uh
are dialects of the same language if
they
are mutually intelligible which means
that
you can understand each other if you
speak two different dialects
but if you don't understand each other
that means they are completely different
languages
so for instance italian and french even
though they are related
but they are different languages because
it's hard to understand
each other if you are speak of french
and you speak with someone uh who's a
speaker
but if you are egyptian and you speak
with someone
from saudi arabia it's easy for you to
understand
each other and here's a map of
the distribution of arabic dialects you
can see here in saudi arabia
there's the nigeria dialect in the
central
region it covers also some
parts of uh jordan iraq and syria
it has the hijazi dialect on the west
coast you have the
gulf dialect and bahrain dialect
and now i'm talking about natural
language crossing
so what is natural language
it's also known as mutation linguistics
it's a intersection between
computer science and linguistics
particularly artificial intelligence and
it aims to study and design language
technologies like spelling correction
and translation fixed analytics
and it's worth mentioning that most of
nlp problems
are ai hard and still unsolved so why do
we need
nlp in fact most of our
communications uh as humans uh
in unstructured structured format
also human language is hard to model
as i mentioned before national languages
are inherently ambiguous
so a word like bank could be something
like river or
financial institution also
people sometimes express
things without meaning they literal
meaning
so sometimes they are being sarcastic
they don't
exactly mean what they say so here's an
example when you say
now max supports one girls and people
associated with
this meme which is mechanical the cheese
cereal
supporting like actual interesting
wonders so they
are being sarcastic here they don't
really mean that
they mean something else and there are a
lot of challenges uh
in the nlp field one of them is scale
sometimes we need to deal with large
tremendous amount of data to do some
real-time
processing also we have to take into
account
language variation you have a lot of
languages each language has
its own dialect and uh
another challenge is unknown
representation we don't know how to
represent
the word knowledge we don't know how to
uh represent some uh concepts
like um common sense how
can we represent common sense to uh
machines so these are some examples of
challenges
even within the field of natural lives
and nlp technologies can be divided into
two categories applications and
core technologies we'll talk about
each of them briefly and next slides
so let's start with applications one of
the most
known applications for natural links
processing is machine translation
i think hopefully most of you have used
google translate so here's an example
from google translate
translating text from arabic into
english
another application is sentiment
analysis
the goal is given some text you want to
say that is this positive negative or
neutral another application
takes classification you have a set of
documents you want to
assign them to predefined classes
so if you have some news articles you
want to
classify them into sports science
politics
etc and here are some
nlp terminologies um i'm going to
talk about them in a moment uh you
usually hear the word corpus and in open
linguistics so what is a corpus
carbs is just body in latin
and in linguistics and nlp we use it to
refer
to a collection of texts and
this collection of text can be in a
single or multiple languages
so in case that multiple languages
we call it usually parallel or corvus
like the rosetta stone it's one of the
oldest examples of
cobra and the corpora can belong to
different general news articles social
media etc
you can have a corpus of field reviews
or tweets
wikipedia articles and usually corpora
are
annotated with some information like
tweets you can have a corpus of
tweets annotated with sentiment forces
or real reviews uh annotated with uh
score which could be the articles
annotated with topics
in this case sometimes it's
self-annotated
and the annotation process is done by
humans
usually
we talked about some nlp applications
there are other technologies
we call them nlp core technologies so
these technologies are used in the
pipeline for other
downstream tasks like machine
translations interventional statistics
classification we use for these
applications
different nlp card technologies examples
for
core technologies tokenization and
segmentation
it's the process of splitting text into
smaller units so you have
a document you split it into paragraphs
or paragraphs into sentences
synthesis into words and so forth um
another example is limitation and
stimming
it's the uh it's reducing
um words into their base format
so in this example we have studies that
being studied
you reduce them all to uh study
uh limitations think are useful to
reduce the noise and sometimes
you don't need all of that information
for some applications
other examples include part speech
tagging
named recognition parsync i'm going to
talk about them
in the next slides so what are
part speech tags there are
also no lexical categories like nouns
verbs adjectives so the task part speech
tagging is to assign
for each word or token uh
one of the part speech tags the tags can
be course coarse-grained like noun
verb objectives so you have a small
number of tags
that cover a larger number of uh
tokens or can be fine-grained like nouns
you can say to proper noun singular
this is plural etcetera
another nlp core technology is
uh named entertainment mission
it's a subtask in prevention extraction
so
in this task uh we are interested in
classifying
named entities queries so you have some
named entities and you want to say okay
this is person
this is the organization this is
location so in this example we have
ramkus organization geopolitical entity
i mean announcer is a person
and here is an example of tokenization
parts speech tagging
ner and limitation using uh magamira
system
or arabic i'm going to talk about this
in the
uh corresponding part so here you have
an example like
the dictionary you can see
verbs in red color so this is part
speech tagging you can see that
words uh has words have been tokenized
also here you can see the limitized
form so words are reduced into
their space form
another task is called chunking or
shallow shadow parsing
here you want to collect tokens together
in order to form some shanks shanks can
be
something like noun phrase verb phrase
preposition phrase
etc another task is parsing
here is an example of something called
dependency parsing
so in parsing we want to say we want to
understand the structure of the sentence
which where is the verb where is the
noun what is this object
another task which is very important
technology is called
net language modeling language models
predicts the probability of sequence
force so
we know that's in english the cat is
small is more likely than
the sentence small the cat is
and one direct application of that
language modules is to predict uh
what is the next given sequence of text
so if
i say something like trial is the
capital of
um of what
the machine will predict probably saudi
arabia
and i'm sure that you all
all of you have used uh autocomplete in
iphone or
android so it's basically language model
and language models used to improve
other tasks like speech recognition
machine translation ocr information
retrieval
so for instance in speech recognition if
i say something
like recognize speech
probably it's the second sentence not
the first
one given that it's more likely to
happen
and uh yeah nlp approaches how can we
build an nlp system we can divide the
approaches into
three uh categories uh full-based nlp
uh where linguists uh write explicit
rules
uh for instance something like if you
see er at the end of the
word uh it's token it's reader
become read er classical machine
learning or
statistical nlp um
people uh or humans extract some
features
and then machines have learned rules
hello
i think someone is not meeting their
mind okay
the third approach is
deep learning where machines learn the
rules and features you don't have to
design or engineer features each
approach has its uh advantage and uh
disadvantages for instance rule-based np
can it's easy to understand
if it's useful if
the domain is limited if you know the
rules
however it's time consuming hard to
scale
it performs very poorly when rules are
not followed
uh classical machine learning uses less
computational resources income
when you compare it with the deep
learning it requires less data
however it doesn't capture semantic
instance it's hard to
capture the semantics that
knows apple and orange
are very similar future engineering
is also expensive um it's hard to
generalize to other tasks for instance
if you
design a sentiment analysis uh system
it's hard to design to generalize that
to something like sarcasm fiction
on the other hand deep learning
approaches now dominant in the field
they can capture semantics they allow
something called transfer learning so
you can
learn tasks sentiment analysis and
transfer what you have learned in that
task
to other tasks also deep learning
approaches
learn representation automatically you
don't have to
give explicit representation for
the data however
they require huge amount of data
and also they require extensive
computational resources
as i said mission learning approaches
are dominant in them
nlp nowadays and in the last couple of
years
deep learning became very popular
however all approaches
to lenient depending on your application
sometimes
rule-based methods can be best for
example if you have
a legal document like that and you want
to extract
articles uh sometimes it's
just the easiest way is just to do some
regular expression and
write some rules in order to extract the
articles without
the need to create some complex machine
learning
models there are
lots of nlp tools available online some
of them
are free some of them licensed perhaps
the
three most common uh nlp tools are
spacey in ltk and stanford
core nmd spacey and nltk are written in
python uh unfortunately they don't
support arabic
very well code nlp has some
arabic models and for
stanford currently you can use it like
server and communicate it with the
communicate with the server using any
programming language
there are different domains in which you
can see nlp
as a direct application healthcare as an
instance people do medical document
analytics
and finance or what's called now
authentic
financial technology people use nlp to
do
some financial sentiment analysis in
order to
forecast the future prices for stock
uh market uh marketing also is another
domain
where people do something like product
internet analysis you have products
to study and analyze how
your customers feel about your product
are they positive are they negative
about it a lot is also another
domain for nlp so let's go
now to talk about uh uh arabic kenobi
uh generally speaking arabic nlp is
harder than
english and nlp for different reasons uh
for the nature of language in comparison
to the english language
also there are less resources with
data sets and tools for arabic nlp when
you compare it with english
and there is less research has been
conducted on the arabic nlp
and there are challenges
in the arabic nlp due to the nature of
the arabic language
orthographic inconsistency people
spill words in arabic differently
also another challenge is morphological
complexity
going to talk about it in a moment uh
dialectical variation
people pronounce words and letters
differently
i think litter of can be
depending on your region there are also
a variety variation in lexical and
pathological
representation
and this is an example where people
spill uh
the same war differently uh this is an
egyptian
dialect might be you can see that
people do not agree on one spilling
here's the frequency for each
word used on google
engine so you can see there's no
consistency in the spelling
another challenge is morphological
complexity of arabic
arabic unlike english is morphologically
rich which means that
code word has many inflected forms
like here you have al khaled
etc while for english
you have only up to six forms for
any word they have saying says saying
except
and the word in arabic carries a lot of
information you can't see
what santa claus has translated into
and we will say it just one word
translate to five words
my third challenge is uh the variation
in arctic dialect you can see here
one word which is now in fourth hour and
there's an ah
you can here's uh there are some
examples of
morphological variation
for different parts of speech in arabic
dialect
and i'm going to talk about some common
pre-processing in nlp
usually when we do some arabic nlp
we start with some pre-processing uh
one common step is to remove
diacritics or harakat because they
usually don't add any meaning and they
add
some noise also we normalize
um characters that frequently mistyped
by people like tamarbota we
normalize it to her we drop hamza like
hamza
on aleph or under aleph we drop it
uh also remove related characters or
tatwaen or kashida
these are commonly processing techniques
for the arabic language
also there is something called
transliteration uh
concentration is the stable for process
time and goals
from the alphabet of one language to
another so in this context
you want to trans uh translate or
convert
arabic script into latin script
here's an example of salaam in arabic
script and latin script
and this is useful to avoid some coding
issues or a few
systems that does not support arabic
scripts also you can read in
many scientific papers about arabic nlp
that people use some translation scheme
because they assume that readers maybe
they can't understand their script
one commonly used concentration scheme
is a backwater concentration
it uses ascii only
only ascii letters and it's one to one
representation
so each arabic letter is represented by
one as escalator and vice versa
it includes all the arabic letters plus
the diacritics and
other characters like
etc
one task uh which is very important in
arabic nlp is i dialect identification
so given a piece of text you want to say
okay which dialect is this is it
is it in hijaz is it an egyptian and uh
it has chem or dialects can be
fine-grained or
coarse-grained like do you want it uh
region level like
this is uh gulf uh
dialect or levant dialect
or maybe you can invite by country or
city or
even subculture within city
and there are different data sets and
tools for arabic uh nlp i'm going to
uh briefly talk about some of them
madar it's a part of uh
madar project at nyu abu dhabi
it's still under development and not
released yet
it's a parallel corpus of more than
of 25 cities from our world
and it's a translation of the basic
traveling expression corpus
uh
and uh sorry yeah you can see here
uh some examples um
for uh sentences in standard arabic
and in different dialects like here we
have jibber dialect and real dialect
um you can
think yes here you have the covers here
and you have also lexicon viewer you
have some words
and there are corresponding uh
translation and different dialects
another data set is arab tweet that was
released in 2018
contains about 2.4
million tweets from 11 regions and
our board covering 16 countries
the corpus was collected from 11 1100
users on twitter
also the corpus has annotated with age
gender and dialect so each uh for each
tweet you know the
age of the person the gender and their
dialect
another i would say model more than uh
date set is
uh arabert it's an arabic language model
based on
google's birth it was released recently
2020
and it was trained uh using
uh 70 million sentences or 23 gigabytes
data
using i think wikipedia and other
corpora
and it has two versions uh arbit
virgin 0.1 it's not segmented so words
are
just written as uh as originally
uh collected and the other versions
segmented so
they use some segmentation scheme
two segment words and then they use
bird to train on the segmented
text another
model that's based on arab earth is
the multi-dialect arabic bird
used the initial they used our bird to
initialize their
weight and then they continued training
using
10 million average tweets covering
different average dialects
so the first one here our birth is an
emitter
while multi dielectric are expert is
in dire
and there are different nlp tools uh i'm
going to talk only about three of them
madame era camel tools rna
so madame era is a morphological
analyzer
it was an effort by different academic
institutions columbia university
and other universities currently it
supports uh
standard arabic and egyptian arabic
people are working on
extension to other dialects including
the saudi dialect
particularly dialect jordanian dialect
rocket dialects moroccan dialect
etc and it's written in java it can be
used as a standalone application you
give it some text
gives you output like
it does some morphological analysis i'll
show you in a moment you can use it in
server mode using
different programming languages you
can't communicate with it
or you can use it as a standard java api
so here's a demo of uh
of madame era this is just a demo uh the
actual application is jar file
so you can see here
something like part speech tagging
these are verbs you have nouns you can
see
here like as the verb
and the gender is feminine singular
etc and madame is licensed
for commercial use you have to pay in
order to use it but for academic use if
you
if you have like a
university email or something you can
ask for
free version
another uh tool or set of tools is
camel tools was released where really
recently it's a collection of open
source and
arabic nlp tools um they have some
pre-processing
uh procedures like transliteration
normalization
they have also named this recognition
sentiment analyzer dialect
identification
you can you can see it here in google
collab i'm going to share the link how
to
install camel tools on google collab
after the talk so here you have
transfiltration
you have like salaam alaikum and
arabic script and here you have the
corresponding
quarter script normalization is
here you remove hamsas you normalize
uh tamar vota here you have
name density recognition
as a person
here we have dialects
identification have five
sentences written in different dialects
so the first one was the
system recognized that as a real dialect
it's a jitter dialect
it says a swan dialect which is in egypt
also there are coated examples from
i believe songs first one here in
moroccan dialect and here is
perot diet or lebanese dial and so
let's say the third example in the
housing
a we can we can print the
probability for each dialect instead of
what is the top predicted dial
so you can see that the top dialect here
is a swan the second one is cairo then
alexandria
so the system ranked them i would say
correctly
because they are very similar especially
when you have very short
sentences it's hard to tell exactly
which dialect
if you want to predict exactly which
city
another tool for camel tools is uh
sentiment and
now the sentiment analyzer
here are three sentences the first
one is positive or i'm good i'm
not
so it also learns the negation
although all words are positive
but because it's negated so it's
predicted it as uh
negative terrorist example is just
neutral it is not positive on it
i i tried some uh examples and
different dialects and it works very
well
like in this isn't real dialect and in
the dialect and this was predicted very
well
very correctly
third collection of tools is rnet was
released
recently it's a deep learning toolkit
for arabic social media
uh it has a set of pre-trained bird
models fine-tuned with the
age and gender dialect identification
using arab tweet uh it says
emotion irony and
sentiment
so in conclusions uh would say that
arabic is hard designing
arabic nlp is harder than english for
different reasons
it has less resources less research has
been conducted on
arabic nlp uh also due to the dialect
still
variation arbite is harder than english
arabic is more
logically more complex than english and
all of that
these add extra challenges to our
weeknote
there are some good news um recent years
there has been a lot of research
conducted in nlp in general and the
arabic penalty in particular
there are more available data sets and
tools
and i would say you can expect that in
near future you will see lots of new
applications
uh for nlp and rv can help you
specifically
also if you have any application or
something i would say there's no big
solution that works for everything
you might need sometimes to develop your
new your own solution or come up with
new solutions
i hope you enjoyed the talk thank you so
much and i'm happy to talk
to take any questions thank you
thank you so much thank you for this
great presentation
um so now we're going to take some
questions to
reply to um so please post your
questions in the chat
we have a question from our team member
uh hassan
is asking about words in english and
many
other languages are splitted by the
space character
between them in arabic some nouns can be
connected to propositions and proverbs
how we can overcome this issue to split
arabic words
okay you are if i understand you you
say in english you just split
word using spaces but it's not
always the case because in english
sometimes you have to write something
like you
are with apostrophe
this uh
me show it and show it in this chat so
it's uh not always the case we need some
more
logical analysis and in arabic we use
something called morphological analysis
so i show you an example of madame era
here
you can see here that
tokenized forms it does tokenization
so you remove the l in order
of from the word or use platitude
and so forth so also be
splitted so be machias
listen to two words does that answer
your question
okay ah yes there is questions i'm sorry
um one of the main challenges with
arabic nlp is the shortage
of the training data especially in
difficult tasks like
question answering what would you
recommend to overcome this challenge
to overcome this challenge
it's hard people still developing uh
other uh tools and
data sets i would say try nowadays we
have
uh strong language models like earth try
to
instead of training everything from
scratch try to use
pre-trained models and fine-tune it on
your
task uh if you don't have data sometimes
you can't learn anything this is general
machine learning i mean
you want to do question answering but
you don't have annotated data
so yeah either you build your own on
dates or
there is no solution i would say if you
don't have labeled examples
okay thank you another question is can
we apply the same data
pre-processing steps followed in english
um any esteeming tools
yeah not always the same i mean are it
for english you don't have normalization
for sum of water for instance
but yeah people think is uh done in
different languages like in english
sometimes you normalize
letters into lower cases like capital
you make it small and you reduce the
noise uh by adding capital and
uh uppercase and lowercase so
and yeah different tools like spacey and
ltk they do a lot of normalization
um okay thank you what is
another question is what is a new method
in the in this field
a new method in this field uh what do
you mean exactly
um maybe she meant um
advanced methods modeling methods
yeah i would say recently people
focused more on language modeling
like pert and
other language modeling techniques
using transformer architecture so
yeah they models like earth
has shown that there are they can
improve a lot of tasks and they can
achieve state-of-the-art performance
without the need of
a large data sets so you pre-train your
model
and general text unsupervised way
then you just use this pre-trend model
on like internet analysis
data dataset without need of huge data
unfortunately now
so yeah this is a new advancement in the
field i would say
uh language models based on transformers
can read about first and other uh like
elmo
elmo is not based on the transformers
what
language gbt2 or gbc3 also other
examples
okay thank you another question is
what's the difference between the
tokenization and segmentation
tokenization and segmentation it's they
are used
i mean it depends on the context they
are usually the same
tokenization is splitting words into
talking segmentation into segments for
some languages like
chinese we use segmentation more often
because the
structure of chinese language but for
arabic
usually tokenization and segmentation
we mean the same thing okay
thank you another question is
language languages language is
changeable with time so with nlp
consider that
in the next years
yeah this is main challenge i mean if
language does not change
we can just come up with rules and
that's it but yeah
it's changes every day
so yeah this is this is a challenge for
annually i would say
okay um some audience want to know how
to install
the camel tool for the camera tools for
uh
yeah here in google collab
uh i will share it with you
it's easy to install i mean you can go
to their
github and find the
installation steps but i i have these
examples on git
i'm sorry google collab so i'll share to
you how to install it on
google okay thank you
um can you shout another question is
from abdullilah can you shed some light
on the work you've done on publishing
and outed
nujada uh corpse uh can we help improve
and prove it somehow uh as an open
source community
can you help and improve it somehow
any favoritism yeah uh
for my uh yeah negative corpus it's
annotated
corpus with uh morphological information
uh it's available i believe in nyu if
i'm happy to share what we have done
we annotated uh corporate and different
dialects
najdi yemeni iraqi syrian
with morphological information
so yeah i'm happy to share for technical
book
for arvik nlp i would say introduction
to uh
arabic nlp by nizar habash it's a very
good book
other than that you can there are a lot
of communities
uh like in nyu abu dhabi they have
good labs you can see the resources they
have
um also i'm happy to share some
resources
with the uh google collab here
and my github i will share it with you
after the talk
okay thank you um any
other favorite technical books on nlp
resources actually for me
i i usually read papers more than books
i'm not like big fan of books to the
other
i read more scientific papers more i
mean everyone has
but yeah there's a famous book by
dan georbuski at stanford university
it's
taught in school at schools
different schools so this is perhaps one
of
good academic books other than that
i use the internet i use i read papers
there are some
technical articles yeah
okay thank you um any recent work that
impressed you
in nlp
recent work i mean
it's hard to tell uh if there's one
single word
as a single word but yeah i mean i
mentioned that before
lan advancement and language models like
birds
gbt etc they changed the field they
completely changed the field
okay thank you i think that's it back to
you
renate
uh okay uh thank you so much sakhar for
your time thank you
thank you so much and uh the very
interesting information you have just
give it to us uh thanks
uh and uh thank you to all the
attendants uh we really appreciate your
time
i would like to remind you all about the
pi data global conference that will take
time
at 11 november in sha allah so please if
you
need to know more informations or to
register
visit by that global website uh thank
you
and thank you so much see you in our uh
future events
thanks thank you so much
bye-bye thank you